98.3 98.4 for me though
ain't that easy to beat a gm ladies and
gentlemen
it was 98.4 to 98.3
so this was some high high accuracy
chester
all right
[Music]
we will play one to d4 which is a move
that i focused on a little bit less in
the speed run
but uh i will now begin to play my real
repertoire i will play the jabal london
guys which you have
hopefully if you've seen my stream you
know that this is okay so he goes e6 now
part of the issue with the jabba london
is that black and play e6 and this
essentially compels white to do what
what does white essentially have to do
here sorry board is not visible
yes uh what is this what does white
essentially have to do here
oh sorry that's weird that should not be
that's weird guys sorry yeah
okay what should white essentially do
here
so the movie four right white has to
transpose to the french
my bad and uh black also has to
transpose the bench now there's many
lines here in the knight c3 french that
i can recommend there's e5
we will play bishop g5 which is the
second main line
i don't particularly know this line of
the french i've always played the tarash
after the game i will explain some of
the subtleties here he goes d takes d4
we go knight takes d4 of course
the knight is untouchable due to the pin
and now bishop b7 and knight pd7 are
black's two main moves
knight bd7 um now we don't need to move
this knight yet we can just continue our
development with knight f3
this is all very normal french stuff and
you guys can see that
you know we have slightly better control
of the center white is slightly better
white's got the pawn on d4 and and
black's got the pawn on e6
so white's marginally better due to my
control of the center but it's really
nothing major because black has no
targets in his position now we have to
take on f6
notice that he's played bishop e7 so
he's eradicated the pin
and now we have to decide where we're
going to put this bishop where do you
guys think that i should put
the bishop on f1
in the meantime
i'm going to write down that i should
give you guys an overview
so bishop d3 definitely we should put it
on d3 because
black is going to castle in in the event
of that the bishop is going to be nicely
aimed
at the general vicinity of the kingside
castle castle
this i'm sure has occurred before and
generally black at some point goes to
five so what what would be a good idea
here
he's gone bishop d7 a little bit of a
passive move
how can we tighten the screws straight
away in the center what can we do here
this move is sort of a very typical move
centralizing a piece
and the move is 95. take up the space
stop him from improving his bishop
and potentially vacate the f3 square for
the queen of hitch
okay h6 no problem bishop h4 no need to
take the knight
we can keep the pressure going
and um you know i meant okay bishop a4
that's a bit of a weird move
and first things first does it threaten
queen takes d4 is that a threat do we
need to defend against that explicitly
or can we make a general improving move
and if we can make a general improving
move
what is that general improving move yes
we don't have to defend against it
because
you guys already know bishop h7 check
and so we can play rookie one
bringing the rook onto an open file and
i love how many people are suggesting
automatically this move
at some point we can chase away the
bishop with b3 but that's not i don't
see what this bishop is doing like big
whoop
it's pinning us on this file like on
this diagonal like big deal
okay so what now do we take the bishop
or do we keep the bishops on the board
what do you guys think
and both is fine yeah i'll i'll make it
lots of lonely
so i'm actually going to keep the
bishops and
i don't think that objectively there's
much of a difference but
it's just kind of my style to keep more
pieces on the board when you have an
even trade
you can trade or you cannot trade i like
to keep more pieces on the board
because it gives me more chances to
attack okay now he goes bishop before
see he harasses this rook
the tempting move is to go rookie four
but after the game i'll show that this
runs into
the very nasty move f5 uh so we're just
going to move the rook
up one square and let me just
write this down because rookie four
seemed like a very tempting rook lift
but it
actually wasn't okay so now he wants to
probably put the knight on before so
we can play a3 to stop him b3 would run
into a knight fork on c3
so you know knight b4 isn't really a
threat because we have bishop b4 in
response to that
we're just going to continue making
marginal improvements to my position i'm
going to unpin myself
so that i can later play b3 if i wanted
to and the queen sort of aims itself
generally at the king side he takes
we take with the bishop centralizing our
bishop he probably wants something like
this
very you know strange play by black but
he's not doing anything horribly wrong
what do we do now um i want to chase
away this knight fact one
fact two i'm a little bit concerned
about the move knight b4 in response to
c4
um but should i be concerned probably
not because then i just have bishop a4
okay um ladies and gentlemen
am i hallucinating here i'm going to
pour myself something clearly
the idea of a3 was so powerful that he
simply
decided not to continue battle
nice win perfect i mean the accuracy was
probably 100
too see soggy that's why you gifted me
20 sips for games like these
this is why you guys all watch the
speedrun 95
i mean he was 93.4 black is just
slightly worse here
the amazing thing is how many people
have done that against you but let's not
stop this from
extracting the lessons from this game so
the move knight c3 guys
um the jabba london is what move in this
position
what move in this position have i played
about 80 80 000 times
i can give you the exact number of
online games
oh my god 10 bucks from frank sinatra
real frank sinatra i never thought i
would be up at 1 30 am reading and
setting a chess book but with you
and charlie's motivation 15 hours of
puzzles later
i'm reading a chess book at 1 30 am
thank you for everything you do
you deserve everything so far and much
more thank you frank the real frank
sinatra for the ten dollars and for the
very sweet message
uh bishop f4 let me tell you guys using
a
little-known website called opening tree
expand this
so this is opening tree this is a great
website you can you can actually
look at all of your all of your games um
and and you can filter them by opening
and stuff so it's really good
it's a good site little known site
yeah it's a great site look at this over
2000 guys it's gonna get to 2200.
it's free you can load your games and
you can load my games in
2300 anyways enough you guys get the
point this
is my bread and freaking butter this
opening is my bread and butter
now why do i like this opening so much
now it's normally called the jabba
london now let me give you guys a little
bit of chess history let me give you
guys a little bit of just history
first and foremost the move knight c3 in
this position the moon knight c3 in this
position is considered
and has always been considered quite bad
why
why does this move uh you know
elicit such repulsion really in
many people's uh opinions
because it blocks the c pawn and why are
you playing d4 if you're not gonna play
c4 you're like
combining e4 and d4 but
in recent years all of these sort of
how should i put it these dogmatic
principles have been completely
reevaluated
and the traditional varusov is bishop g5
in this position so
the first time that this occurred was in
1889 by
a famous player named isidor gunsberg
and his opponent here played e6 they had
transposed them to the french which is
what we had on the board
but uh the varasov has never really
caught on black and played bishop f5
and it restricts your cpun but with the
jabal london
white essentially is going after several
ideas here
which taken together allow this to work
the first is that
knight b5 is actually a very serious
idea
now you guys might look at this life i
think is hey are you serious daniel
this i mean knight a6 just defends the
pawn what are you trying to go for well
that knight on a6 is very out of place
and now i actually can move the pawn to
c4 so this can be kind of like a
souped-up queen's gambit
but the second idea is that after bishop
f5 does anybody know
how white usually you know sort of
gets things going on the king's side
here this is a very unusual idea
yeah so f3 and now a move that would
have made like wilhelm stein it's cringe
okay more than cringe laugh me off the
board
g4 and h4 and case in point this
position first occurred
in the year 1995 the first person to
play this was a hungarian fm in 1995
that is
nothing nobody had played this before
nobody thought of doing this and so
nowadays
we can get away with this and i've had
this position a million times as well
white gets this pressure going and this
gets very very interesting positions
anyways
just a little bit of an overview if you
want a
sideline that has tricks that will teach
you about playing unorthodox positions i
highly recommend the job of london
i have a couple of students who play it
full-time over the board
i've been a couple gm's with it over the
board as well
okay so in the game he plays the move
knight f6 and he plays z6 that's one of
the downsides is you have to be ready to
transpose to the french because
if you play bishop f4 then that kind of
allows bishop b4 and that's kind of
unpleasant
so you kind of have to do this and so
bishop g5 is normal
there should be a d take c4 knight takes
c4 knight bd7
knight f3 we're just developing our
pieces and black gets a very very solid
position right
takes f6 notice that we can't just
nonchalantly develop because now black
has unpinned himself
so we play knight f6 bishop d3 castles
castles
and it's kind of like a karo khan set up
now in this position
i'm just checking really quickly what
the theory is because i'm curious myself
so this is all normal this should be
seven
i mean you get this these kinds of
structures and many openings exactly
yeah so this is over a thousand games um
actually
knight takes f6 is a little bit less
common bishop d3 is the main line no
it's still very common castles main move
castle's main move
and uh in this position let's take a
look
b6 is the main line so normally people
do try to deal with this bishop but they
do it by fianchettoing
the problem with bishop d7 is that
deploying the bishop like this allows 95
and white is better 10 games have gone
this way
and uh white has just better place
pieces more control of the center
and unfortunately he resigned before
things could end could get interesting
the only thing i wanted to talk to you
guys about is sort of this moment how do
you decide
between taking on e7 and dropping the
bishop back to g3 well i would say that
the difference between them is pretty
small
but generally speaking um
you know when you've got more space it's
a good idea to keep pieces on the board
and you might look at this bishop and
say well what is it doing
um well it's guarding the f4 square and
it's supporting the knight
as i always say the pieces not all
pieces have to be doing something very
specific all of the time
yeah like no country for old men flip a
coin anywhere but you poke it
anywhere
so yeah queen takes c7 here and maybe
his queen can come to d4 so i decided to
to not do that
and uh here i decided not to play rookie
4
because it would have it would have
allowed f5 and this bishop on g3 would
have gotten him
in very big trouble so i decided to move
the rook up to e2
so why did i go queen c1 and not queen
d2 um
i actually don't really know i kind of
missed windy too honestly
yeah i just kind of escaped my attention
guys um i i think i might have been
worried about this move but
i can just go c3 that's not a problem so
yeah queen e2 would have been more
accurate and of course here
just when i was about to play a3 to
bring the square under control
and then play c4 with an advantage but
not with a big one
um computer gives the computer does give
plus 1.5 though i mean the two bishops
combined with the way that they are
aimed gives white a very very good
position so he decided to resign
yeah or juba does stream as well
yeah so rookie four uh is a very
automatic move right oh let's lift the
rook up but after f5
you're all of a sudden in trouble
because if you move the rook back then
f4 and
that bishop is actually trapped so does
that make sense to everybody
like the way that this game not not a
spectacular game we can play another
one but a couple of instructive things
what database is called megabase it's
part of chess space
all right great next game let's play one
more five minute and then we'll do
some 10 minutes
yeah some sometimes things like this
happen
yeah rook h4 he can still go up four
though i think
okay thanks again guys for all of the
support in the early going
this means so very much to me
um i would i usually draw the threshold
at 1800
i think if you're like 1800 2000 and
above you could definitely benefit from
chess space but
really leeches has all of the tools that
you would need honestly so
i don't know i'm kind of on the fence
about it
okay i don't think we had a stream
sniper it looks like there might not be
too many opponents at this high level
because they play three minute
at a high rating let me open the window
it's a beautiful
early morning
nice and crisp 30 degree morning
in the south this is tea
loose leaf tea all right we got it we
got an opponent
okay let's go e4 this time very serious
guy 2467
from georgia georgian players are good
we're at that russian school of chess
north carolina is the south come on
okay and let's play i'm gonna play my
real openings guys
so my main opening is the right lopez
and the overlay is messed up i don't
believe it is
is it messed up i mean the clocks are a
little bit messed up i'm sorry about
that
well it's less south than south carolina
can't see the opponent oh crap sorry
one second guys yep i got it
all right what is wrong here
so where is this sorry give me a second
please this happens sometimes
yeah there we go all right now you
should be able to see the opponent
and uh what is this called he plays the
berlin
he plays the berlin and i will once
again play
what i usually okay no he doesn't play
the ball he plays d6 that's
uh sort of the deferred steinitz and
black uh
creates the thread of knight takes c4
what should we do here with white
there's a couple of ways that we can
play this position but you guys
should have a good finger on the pulse
of how i like to play it
so i like to yeah so rookie one is one
possibility but i like to strike
immediately in the center when my
opponent plays passively
i like to open the position up and we
open the position up in the rye lopez by
going d4 and taking with the knight
obviously if he takes knight takes c4
then we can take twice on c6 now
uh is a moment where people already
struggle uh you don't actually need to
take on c6 we can just
wait this out and and develop our knight
to c3 if black plays knight takes d4
which is actually quite typical in these
positions
then i will take his bishop and deploy
my queen to d4
all right now uh let's pay attention to
a couple of things first of all this
tension right we
can take on c6 and a lot of people
actually do if we were to
take on c6 what would we want to take
with this is a tricky question
the knight of the bishop
because if you apply like standard
opening principles you would think well
the position is open
so i'd want to preserve the bishop but
the reality is taking with the knight is
worse
and part of the reason is that when we
take with the knight he recaptures with
the pawn with tempo
we have to move the bishop here take a
very good hard look at this knight
that knight has a lot of prospects and
it can potentially go to f5 how do we
prepare knight f5
and with this next move we're not only
going to prepare knight five but that's
going to be part of the idea
how do we make sure that after knight f5
bishop takes f5 we don't have to take
with a pawn which is kind of awkward
what should we do don't be afraid to
move that lady guys
absolutely don't be afraid to move that
lady
and the other threat that we're creating
and this is actually an inaccuracy
i have fallen into this myself with
black does anybody else
see what it is that we can do in
addition to knight fun
take a look at this type 2 undefended
pawn ladies and gentlemen do you see
that the queen is x-raying it
do you see that the knight is putting
pressure on it boom go
e5 ruins black's pawn structure even
further it opens up
and i have to speed up a little bit now
look at black's pawns all isolated
weak our queen is beautiful white is
better here this is all theory by the
way
and uh do we want to trade queens no
we're going to drop our queen back to c4
so that it continues to pressure
the c7 pawn okay rook beat is a great
move
it stops our bishop from developing
because then he would take
one how do we resolve such a problem and
this is this is still definitely within
the balance of theory
how do we resolve that problem in the
simplest possible way we can play the
move
b3 right we can cement the pawn he can
play rook b4 we'll drop our queen back
to e2 not a problem
okay queen d4 so i guess
we now have a dilemma right we can take
the queen that slightly corrects this
pawn structure
i'm actually going to make a move which
a lot of people will find objectionable
i'm going to play bishop e3
and i know you guys might look at this
and say well why are you ruining your
own pawn structure i'll explain this in
detail after the game we have less than
two minutes
but the bottom line is is this idea of
knight t5 here
allows me now to correct my pawn
structure and once again i think get an
advantage in the end game
whether or not i will convert it is
another question this guy is really good
so we are going to have to be super
precise i'm going to take this pawn on
a7 to create a passer
on a2 the reason that i'm optimistic
here is because
i do have a pass spawn and black does
not yet have a pass spawn
you guys already know that when you're
looking at an end game you want to pay
attention first and foremost
to well other than the material who's
got the past pawns
okay so he decides not to take this pawn
all right so we're going to defend it
then
we are going to defend it with our rook
and if he goes f4 then we can redeploy
the bishop through
c1 to b2 i hope this is making sense so
far
now let's play the move f3 uh since he's
given us the chance
i'm going to meet f4 now with bishop f2
okay he's gone okay eight though that's
a good move
yeah i have to say this guy is not
bending at all
this guy is not bending to my will at
all let's go rook d3 just to shift the
rook up to c3
this might end in a draw although we'll
see
i might also lose this one
okay let's go here okay five
that's a bit of an odd move okay let's
go let's do one
yeah i'm getting that sense that i'm i'm
getting soundly outplayed here rook c6 i
want to push this pawn up
okay let's push that pawn up to c5
hmm okay let's go here
and now if he takes my pawn i'm gonna
move my king away and then i want to
take this one of course
f4 this is really interesting stuff
okay okay this is um
f4 really riley tvs thank you
all right guys i hate to be that guy but
okay so bishop d2
i think might hold the draw here
although by the hair on my chinny chin
chin
okay thinking here you see
not a huge fan of the time he's spending
on these obvious moves but okay
no we'll look at the game i'm not
suspicious but he is very strong
this is gonna end in a draw if i'm
careful
okay he might if he plays around like
this he's going to lose
but he's not going to play around like
this
well basically i'm going to try to push
this pawn to d7
11 january yeah i don't know guys
i'm going to torture him a little what
is this
wow king e7 that's just that's some
serious business right there
yeah something is off he's taking like
five seconds on only moves
but this will be a draw
i will try to flag him and basically the
reason i will try to flag him ladies and
gentlemen is because
he is taking five seconds for every
single move so if i can play a couple
free moves and check him
that's the bottom line i can pre-move
this and i can make up a lot of time in
the five seconds he's spending per move
f3 i mean f3 would be played instantly
by most people
but i will not make any direct
accusations we'll review the game
he's also not playing this perfectly
like he's
he's definitely going to draw this but
he's making it a little harder himself
as you guys can see
it's definitely weird just the way he's
playing this i mean but okay
well still a very instructive game no
doubt about it
thank you temper i mean you guys see
what i'm saying right i'm not
being unreasonable here
hopefully i'm not being too unreasonable
it's it's the five seconds for every
single move
and their fluctuation between certain
moves are really good and other moves
are just really bad
one two three four it's every every
single move and this is a repetition of
moves there's nothing i can do here
i mean unless i i mean i can try to do
something like this and just flag him
this is a little distasteful
but because i'm pretty convinced that he
is up to something
you can count it like a metronome it's
literally four seconds per every single
move
one two three
four boom one it's a metronome put on
the metronome two three
four five boom
i mean he's going to i mean this is
unreal
i'm going to flag him i mean what do you
what what am i expected to do in such a
situation
this is uh this is actually hilarious
that he doesn't realize he's going to
flag
he's got less time and that's it maybe
it's his internet but i don't think so
yeah i'm sorry guys sorry for the
flagging but
if it's someone like this you know this
is just ridiculous
and now he's played fast he played one
move fast yeah goodbye
good bye okay
that is some very very
sketchy play all right
98.3 98.4 for me though
ain't that easy to beat a gm ladies and
gentlemen
it was 98.4 to 98.3
so this was some high high accuracy
chest here all right now it's hard to
win this position though that's the
reason it ended in a draw i mean i
didn't make any mistakes
i didn't make any big mistakes um and
and so
it was a drawn position before you know
before
he could really manufacture any chances
okay so
this is all theory i'm quite sure of it
let me just check i mean because it
seemed like he equalized very easily
and i don't remember black supposing to
equalize this easily
one sec i mean i'm not going to make any
claims for sure but
boy was that suspicious play
i mean that that was just some weird
stuff going on okay so this e5
d e yeah 31 games
yeah so queen c6 okay so queen d6 is
correct that's main line and now rook b8
is five games
so a couple recent grand master games
actually continued exactly like this
and now b3 is is one game from 1999
queen d4 yeah so we're following one
game from 1999 here white took on d4
but um i decided to play bishop b3 so
in this position i think i made a small
air
um i played the move b3 and the reason
behind this move was
very clear which is to deploy the bishop
to e3 that's the ideal square for the
bishop and if i go there immediately
then i just blunder the pawn the problem
is
i forgot that he can bring his queen to
d4 and sort of force a queen trait on
his terms
so i should have gone rook to d1 should
have gone rook to d1
and attacked the queen and then his
queen has to move and then maybe i can
play b3
um so he goes queen d4 i go bishop b3
and i made a small misjudgment here i
still thought it was better
the reason i thought i was better is
first of all i'm attacking his pawn
which is something and second of all i
thought this pawn on c4
is a you know basically
allows my knight to access d5 so i
thought eventually i'm going to play
knight t5 and i'm going to correct
my pawn structure which is what happened
i corrected my pawn structure
i no longer have doubled pawns the
problem is he's got very active pieces
right and he deploys the rest of his
pieces to very nice squares
and here this move f5 is fishy i mean no
i mean i think most humans would take
most humans would also not give up a7 i
mean rook a4 is automatic here for me
and um you know he plays this in this
very very precise way king f7 he doesn't
rush with f4
and ultimately he you know is able to
get a dead drawn position
and now this move bishop d2 is crucial
by the way so he reached this position
and after f4 here's the problem guys if
you play c
takes d6 you might look at this and say
wait a second d takes c7 and the pawn is
unstoppable it is
who can spell out for me the whole line
black wins here
black strikes first dude it's got to be
an executive order thank you tesco
dude i'll be happy if there's a special
commission dispatch for anti-cheating
i think we can whatever our political
beliefs we can all agree
we need to target justice
okay so i go here boom boom now normally
this is a draw
but here here comes johnny
and now i can go rook two and i can also
simply take and goodbye to the king rook
g1
um so that's the bottom line why
couldn't i take on f4 i
could but then black at least has a draw
piggy is on the seven black at least
there's a draw and i actually at this
point started to flirt with
flagging and bishop d2 puts the bishop
sort of you know almost shielding it
with its body
rook takes d2 as force uh if black's
bishop moves then i take on c7 with
check and i've got these connected
passers
um and and it's anybody's game so he
takes
and um we get this dead drawn rook and
four versus rook and four
where eventually i'm going to give up my
pass spawn for one of his pawns which is
what happened
but he he missed with king f6 i mean
king f7 is
is just a dead draw king f6 allows this
this little maneuver and i
i was able to win a pawn ultimately so
he sacked the spawn he lost it
and i flagged him but this was all
actually top computer moves nonetheless
so we did play stockfish i'm pretty sure
guys i'm going to send in a report and
please do not misinterpret this as me
like
100 saying he's cheating but chess.com
does have an excellent
detection method that they will use make
the appropriate judgment
yeah all right goodbye
um great so that
is the couple of five minute games
marred by some weird stuff going on
but hopefully you found them instructive
[Music]
nonetheless